what up guys welcome to another episode
of pearl daily on the just pearly things
YouTube channel before I start make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell like the
video on your way and also guys we are
dropping two more t-shirts so not only
can you be the ultimate alpha male and
have women come up to you left and right
um with your women shouldn't vote shirt
you also can have women tell you how
awesome your t-shirts are with this
exclusive Edition One of a Kind women
shouldn't drive shirts and on top of
that we also have repeal the 19th so if
you guys want to get yourself a t-shirt
the link is in the description that's
the audacity Network dot store that's
the audacity Network dot store we have a
couple of different stories today and
what I like about this weekend stories
is it really just shows you know I try
to paint a picture of what is going on
in society and I'll tell you guys
something that irritates me a little bit
is when people come in and say red
pillars are doomsdayers I say that red
pillars live in reality and
unfortunately we have a lot of people
that are trying to sell you a dream and
I just can't do that do you know how
easy it would be for me to sell the
future is so bright and amazing but the
truth of the matter is birth rates are
dropping promiscuity is on the rise I
don't see there being less only fans
models in 10 20 years and I really wish
I could say that I predict something
different but I mean when you have the
big Banks like Morgan Stanley all
predicting that most women are going to
be single and childless and half the
people that get married are going to get
divorced that's the majority not having
a happy ending
um you know and I could sit here and
sell you a dream
and I would but I would then that would
make me someone that just tells you what
you want to hear and that sorry
um and the truth of the matter is we're
in a post-marriage world and the
marriage we see today isn't marriage so
um I'm gonna give you guys an example so
what What is marriage marriage is two
virgins coming together they typically
marry young and when we think of a
traditional
pure marriage there are two virgins they
come together Young
um ideally the the man works his way up
to protect and provide the woman takes
care of the home she has wife skills and
the issue is we really have three
generations of zero wives
um now I know what you're thinking
there's always exceptions but it doesn't
make the rule and when I interview
people I I categorize people in four
different groups so we have the 80 to
100 year olds which I really see as the
last generation of wives the women 80
plus
um the majority believed in obeying
their husband
um they stayed home they took care of
the children they had traditional skills
and their daughters which are the 60 to
80 year olds
typically
um adopted a very fearful mindset this
is when the propaganda really really
took off that generation so they while
they did they were taught to be wives
they had traditional skills they taught
their daughters wrong and they told
their daughters to focus on themselves
focus on their careers always have a
backup plan right and that typically
like what is true femininity when you
think about it
um do you think the farmers of times
past were really worried about I don't
know makeup hair
I mean like the elite women were but the
average peasant's wife no guys no and
let's stop selling these dreams to
average women that were the Queens we're
not the Queens most of us are just lowly
peasants wives yes ladies yes so okay so
that generation you see a loss of skills
this is where you see the women that
really don't know how to do anything a
lot of very lazy entitled spoiled women
because the media is telling us we're
amazing all the time social media is
telling us we're amazing our husbands
are told they can't tell us the truth
because happy wife happy life so the 40
to 40 to 60 roughly year olds are the
first generation of what I would say
shitty wives a lot of these women
prioritize themselves first a lot had
nannies they went to school they weren't
at home
um it was a me me me generation
um and that birth of my generation the
generation of women so bad that we're
not making it down the aisle
um we have more only fans models than
teachers
we have zero wife skills we just thought
you know and some of us are taking
initiative to learn but uh overall a lot
of us you know
there's a lot of craziness that the men
have to deal with now this brings me to
the Dylan danis and Logan Paul fight so
as you guys know where you may not know
Dylan danis and Logan Paul
um have a boxing match coming up in
mid-october and coming up to this fight
Dylan danis has just a known like trash
talker and I think that's why uh Logan
Paul picked him but the issue was it
kind of blew up in Logan's face a little
bit where you know he's really getting
humiliated for everyone to see because
Dylan is tweeting so many pictures of
Logan's fiance with all of her exes and
you know I was thinking about how the
generation of shitty wives the 40 to 60
year old women they would go to college
they'd have maybe crazy high school
years but then they'd get married in
their early 20s so what they did was
limited but in all honesty if things
were being recorded back then do you
think Logan's the only guy that's in
this position
I mean a lot of men just aren't aware of
what they you know married a lot I mean
Nina's women like Nina get married every
day the difference was it was documented
for her
um and you know this has a lot of
repercussions in society you know
um most women when we go back to the
traditional marriage which is being a
virgin it doesn't really exist anymore
we're really in a post-marriage society
with a lot of people just playing
pretend and calling it marriage but
they're not religious most people
they're not virgins most people
um and we're really again post-marriage
world we just it's a lot of playing
pretend so what's going on this week is
Nina has now filed a restraining order
against Dylan danis and allegedly Dylan
has been obtaining these photos through
a hacked Snapchat and apparently they
were hacking her phone so if that is
true you know obviously that's illegal
so you can't do that Dylan is arguing
that all of the stuff he's posting was
public knowledge and on the internet so
I I don't know it's kind of he said she
said at this point but Dylan has tamed
it down a little bit I haven't seen any
crazy pictures of Nina
um this crazy picture bomb that he was
gonna post hasn't been posted so I guess
we'll see
um now Logan is posting a video with
Nina
um
babe I'm hot
[Music]
all right do you have a feather in your
hair use your muscles
I don't care do you want to slushie or
not
all right here we go okay let's go yeah
is my feather gone yes
I'm so stressed
oh you gotta have a cup of salt water so
we turn it on oh hey
exciting
let me just wait
[Music]
wow it's working oh
[Applause]
like all my friends on Facebook are like
out of their children okay you're crying
okay
[Music]
wow
that's great oh that's good you know
what I think this should motivate women
to get a personal trainer because really
if you're hot enough you can overcome
anything you know what I mean I'm like
you know okay anyways
um so let's look at the comments it says
it took Logan two years to build this
relationship and Dylan nuked it in two
weeks you mean the world to me means
she's been with the whole world uh bro
just kissed the whole of Hollywood she's
so sweet I'm sure she's not been ran
through by everyone in Hollywood you
know it's unfortunate if I was Logan
honestly I would just put her out of the
Limelight like there's no reason she
needs to be in the videos
um I I mean I wouldn't advise going
through with this I think it's just
gonna come with a lot of problems but if
he wants to go through with it I I
really think he's just got to take her
out of the Limelight
it because at least for the time being
now um you know Logan's trying to fire
back and we've seen Logan you know put
out some stuff but it hasn't really
stuck but now I I guess they they've
leaked a video of Dylan training so
basically saying he's gonna lose this
fight so uh Dylan says Shane Mosley was
right the Paul sends spies into camps
for any advantage because they suck but
it's okay with 20 seconds left in the
round my partner who's a 15 time
Brazilian World kickboxing champion said
let's go for it I'm not afraid to sit in
the pocket and trade blows let's see who
takes the first step back on Fight Night
honestly guys I don't know anything
about boxing is that him getting I guess
he's getting his ass kicked there so a
question
that a lot of people have is because you
know Nina's alleging that
he is getting his information by hacking
her phone that that's what's a legend
right
um so now Dylan is coming in and given
his side of the story um to Aiden Ross
because Aiden Ross did a stream I guess
with both of them with him here's the
thing about the fight right how do you
have so much ammo on this guy
like seriously a lot more every day I
wake up good morning it's you on Twitter
50 000 likes on this picture in two
hours well the girl dated like over 200
guys but it's like how do you where do
you find this where's your ammo
they send you the people they send me
the pictures
I think I responded to you right
literally no way yeah
[Music]
you don't think he does they're Brothers
I don't know like fake Brothers
got a message I'm gonna say what they
say I'm gonna I'll I'll ask I'll ask
Logan striking back here he says Dylan
spending his life stalking my fiance
instead of training I I'm surprised
Logan hasn't gotten any real like dirt
on him I haven't really seen because I'm
just thinking with all of this you would
see like something crazy